alright okay let me see do I look it
okay what I look like just zoom in on my
face alright ladies and gentlemen
welcome to Wow
anyway this is the singing by Chris so I
always offer the guests to sing it right
so let me see what you got that's right
I just want to be that guy yeah you know
we live in Riften with Griffin I like it
I want it that's been my dream always to
be the talking guy to be the talking gay
boys to men all right to the podcast
[Music]
Chris D'Elia
the youngest man alive I'm surprised
you're not gonna be doing that on a ham
and Amtrak next yeah actually that song
for real is what you just played is so
dope I wish there was more music like
that well this is a group that called
the dopa pot oh that's a real song yeah
yeah they made it for me that's why I
says oh okay I figured you just no no
you know what I did was I put it out
there I was like I want to do I need me
theme music and I was like what I first
started he started doing yeah I was just
singing like a karaoke song right or
than what was happening as I was getting
copy right so yeah he started sending me
original music alright I saw you I saw
that you know and so then this is a
group to send me like the original song
so I've got I got like 30 original songs
from people oh wow but that's the one I
went with as my theme song but ladies
and gentlemen welcome to the podcast and
this is my good friend for many many
years mr. Chris D'Elia
it's been a long yeah I'm happy to be
here finally I've been so busy and I'm I
was able to work it out now sorry I
pushed it maybe two or three times yeah
you know it's funny that you say that
though because I'm on the episode like
something like sixty uh-huh and I think
Whitney Cummings is on episode like six
oh she did it already
Wow and she's probably busier than I am
yeah well I'm just saying you went on
her podcast yeah I knew hers was
probably gonna do numbers
no no it's good III know you know what
it is no honestly it's not that it what
it is is I feel like I [ __ ] out like
Oh her just because yeah yeah she put
you on that really bad you know what I
wouldn't say to you and I say to you all
the time but I want to say it on the
podcast publicly is like one thing I
admire about you that I like about you
so much is that the first day I ever met
you you're still the same guy that's
actually you said that recently to me
that's I that made me feel I think about
that all the time that you said that
makes me feel so good and I'm so happy
that you say that yeah because it's the
truth I'll be just like you I don't know
you just have a weirdness about you
you're not like a normal person you know
in a sense that you just you're quirky
yeah yeah you're quirky dude yeah and
here you are very successful it's really
happening excited breath being at the ha
yeah well I was trying to think of when
we met it was how Honda is probably
chosen six or something sorry I have to
be didn't you stop you did stand up and
then you stopped yeah I was doing it and
then I stopped and then it was like mm
it was like 2003 is when I got back into
it and that my road was like I went I
was doing like open mics whatever and
then I started doing the long beach
laughs not long beach that was in
Marietta and the Queen Mayor Mary I did
that oh I did that once
I think it was with I want to say Sam
Tripoli yeah and then I don't know why I
think I did it with him but I think I
did but it was just terrible yeah it was
just a weird thing yeah so I went from
dear then I started doing that annex
room at the ice house yeah yeah yeah
they used to have those three shows like
Friday yes Saturday so wait so you did
it
so 2003 was when you came back yeah I
came back okay and then when you did you
do before that how long oh man it was
like eight years before that cuz I was
30 when I came back and so I was like it
was like I was like 22 what you started
oh yeah man I did a class at UH at the
extensions taught by Sister line DS yeah
Wow yeah like sandy sure taught the
class you know how and then I was like
you know my first time ever doing
stand-up for the showcase was in the
original room and then it took I'm not
how dude that's so funny to think about
I don't know because it took me like I
want to say 50
years later before I became like a
regular at the comedy yeah I think I
became a regular before you did tonight
this is what I'm saying so I went to the
annex didn't from the annex I started
doing spots at the heart right right
we were both heavy at the holidays long
time then I remember when you were like
you you started going yes yes yes and
you were doing like the belly room right
and all this stuff but you you already
on your path my tommy was like he's yeah
he liked me a lot yeah he wanted he like
I always say Tommy was like Christopher
Columbus with you yeah because he thinks
he discovered he would've made it no
that's funny he did help me a lot though
and yeah yeah that way but but uh yeah
because I remember when I first got to
the haha I remember you know sometimes
guys would come and you were like oh wow
he's here at the haha cool and he would
kill but most of the people who were
there on a regular basis weren't like
really good yeah they could be really
good but you were the only guy that was
at the haha on a regular basis that was
really good and always really good and I
remember thinking like I remember I
wasn't intimidated by you cuz you're
always very nice but you were like the
guy that was like okay this guy knows
what's up he's funny I can't be a
[ __ ] idiot around Genet I mean like I
always want to be on my best behavior
well it wouldn't when did that change
literally the week after yeah I know but
do we you had like a such a dynamic rise
I was talking about you on the
documentary they're gonna do on the
other Comedy Store will the coms I
forgot the guy's name my binder yeah my
he's just you know and I was just saying
like I think it's like you know you know
it's interesting it's just great when
like somebody you're close to and your
friend actually makes it so whatever you
could have a little bit of envy yeah of
course
most of it is like oh I'm so glad this
is happening then oh this sweetie yeah
but also dude here's the other thing man
like and like you know I think people
assume that there's a lot of hate in the
comedy world for each other like I don't
really feel that I don't really even
even if it happens I don't pay attention
to it I don't give a [ __ ] like what what
what the people who do hate or have a
little bit of that in them but they
don't realize is that like
dude when you do well I do well yeah
yeah when I do well more comics do well
it's just like I mean do you know how
many [ __ ] people have been at my
shows and been like hey you were the
first comedian I ever really kind of
started watching and and you put me on a
Theo you put me on the [ __ ] you you
put me on a [ __ ] yeah it's like that it
just helps again though that's just a
testament to you man it's not you're
saying that but I think it has to do
with like your thing cuz you've always
been on the cusp of like excuse me like
technology and stuff like that cuz I
remember when ye like you know snapchat
came out and you were like oh yeah I
don't know I also like doing it I think
like I think comics kind of figured out
how to like doing it now but and I
wasn't like the first to do it of course
but like by any means but like the but I
was I really liked doing it and I
remember a lot of comedians being like I
don't wanna have to do that and I was
like you don't have to but it's fun and
it really helps okay you know I mean
yeah I'm right you know it's funny I
remember I used to tell you do you guys
so much I was would tell you I think oh
you did yeah yeah you know what I
remember the first time you sold a
t-shirt you like bro I just I didn't
want to do it um well the reason why I
didn't want to do is cuz I didn't want
to have to do it at the shows oh that's
what I thought merch was yeah but once I
was like oh I could just kind of sell it
online yeah and then the podcast lent
itself to that and then I really just
kind of laid into it which was more it
was funnier to me rather than like being
like you guys can buy this like I'm not
that guy I'm like bro you buy this [ __ ]
because this is like the coolest [ __ ] oh
my god it is daily [ __ ] [ __ ] clothes
wrong that's crazy you know yeah well
you're always really kind of a
fashionista I just feel like you're
gonna be on stage you know it's like
yeah but you're giddy but as you're
getting older I've done bro I am Telling
You right now are things gonna change
yes and I know I've been saying
but I just don't feel like bro I'm gonna
get a [ __ ] green cape and I'm not
[ __ ] with you dude I'm gonna get a
green cape with a [ __ ] pendant and it
dependants gonna keep the [ __ ] in the
neck and the shit's gonna come up like
I'm a [ __ ] Marvel villain and I want
it to come just above my head that's
what I want it was gonna be but what's
gonna be annoying about it is this is
gonna be like all the fans are gonna
show up with a copycat
but you wearing the cave is gonna be
fine for me but it's gonna be like these
[ __ ] D'Elia fans who are gonna be
just like that's gonna be like you're
like Dane Cook's fingers your thing I
tell people the D'Elia cape
I tell people uh oh it was gonna say I
tell people uh I tell people to wear my
March on other people's shows yeah Kalyn
and [ __ ] yeah that's my favorite people
come up to me like what people asked us
all really cool yes well here I am and
I'm happy to be here nah but you i've
always [ __ ] we've been friends for a
long time and i think you're [ __ ] you
know i'm on your podcast so people that
these are your fans but I mean dude this
guy's the real deal he's funny as [ __ ]
and I love [ __ ] hanging with him so
well here we go you there there's the
endorsement right as well not lately I
can start you know there you go didn't
this career in gear
but you you [ __ ] do well you know you
know what the problem is that we're at a
place like the Comedy Store and like
right now I think there's like like when
you look back on this time I think
you're gonna look back on it it's gonna
be like how they looked back yeah on
i-70 sure no because with the podcasting
yeah definitely transition into like
this new cuz look just like what you're
saying earlier how people like I don't
want to do that there's so many people
they were like I don't want to be on
Twitter and stuff and it was like we're
at that transition right now and like
you were like you were in the head you
know you you know me you were the leader
in that amount of stuff I mean what do
you how do you think it's changed from
when even from when we first started oh
wow
well I mean to me it was always like an
extension but to me it's just like
having an audience like you're online
like like and I don't I think that the
thing was to with like comedians they'd
think like I do stand-up that doesn't
translate to the two apps and [ __ ] like
Instagram and it's like
it doesn't really unless you're just
posting a stand-up clip but in the
beginning you couldn't but you could but
you could you could I liked figuring out
how to be funny on that platform yeah
cuz it's for an audience and I just feel
like now here's the thing man
I'm I'm still [ __ ] squeaking out my
30s but but I feel like the finish line
yeah I know I know but I feel like now
you know with Instagram and you know I
don't really use snapchat but like
Instagram and like what else is there
Twitter and stuff and stuff but like
that is there kind of here to stay
Instagram is still really big Facebook I
don't really use but like to me I feel
like finally I feel like the old guy
with tick tock you know I mean and now
it's like I don't know what to do
and and I posted one or two tick tocks I
thought that just Azzam but to me I'm
just always doing it to make fun of it
right but like people are really doing
tick tock yeah they're out the day out
here do I kind of know but I love was
like what is split screen yeah I don't
know I don't know yeah I don't know but
so you know I I think that you know I
was thinking what's gonna be the next
one like after Instagram and then vine
and then snapchat and it's definitely
ticked I mean take like is enormous
its own but they're to me they're all
big whatever app is out there people get
on it cuz it's so simple you know but
it's like to me Twitter and Instagram
are still gonna be the kings because if
you have an app like tick tocking and on
the app it says post to Twitter or
therefore they're the best you yeah cuz
I feel me if I was taking art I would
not have that option on my app I don't
want you going to Twitter I want you
just coming to take yeah but then that
but then tick tock becomes but then it's
all it's so [ __ ] what do you call it
a city says oh yeah and like it then
then you know I would even know what
tick tock was probably if that didn't
happen right no but still I mean it's
just I mean it's just amazing like that
like becae I feel like your personality
lent itself to easily translating to the
internet because again
people don't realize it's like this
crazy person that you are on Twitter
yeah you're the executor yeah and then
so that's why it is harder for some
people yeah yeah yeah yeah the same
reason why they can't like you ever see
somebody like do like an acting thing
and you're kind of like oh that guy's
not good at that mmm but they're
hilarious yeah yeah yeah you know it's
that kind of thing so maybe people are
people are suffering with that kind of
yeah I don't know I think people take it
too seriously to like yes but it's weird
now though you can get [ __ ] canceled
off of some serious [ __ ] you don't even
mean it
ever since that one we talked about
early that was I forgot what two guys
the guy who got fired from SNL ever
since that happened and from something
he said on his podcast it made me start
to go now let me just be careful you
know I guess so yeah I mean I don't know
his his uh the thing is is like I I
didn't really see that clip I saw like
it moved a little bit out of context
yeah me too but um but it stand-ups
funny that guy yeah so I've only really
seen his stand-up and then that little
clip so I don't know I don't know what
to even make it by the way I would hope
he's funny
yeah also no yeah they said we want you
to be as familiar so obviously he was
funny yes it was just like this one
little I don't know I just what I mean
what do you think about this like
canceled culture this like you know that
the sensitivity because as I watch you I
don't think you necessarily worry about
it because you always stay I'm staying
in a pocket anyway I guess so yeah I
don't know I mean I'm a dude I think
that I'm so [ __ ] silly that it's like
you know you don't I don't know also if
you listen my podcast if you like really
listen to my podcast and you don't take
it out of context like I think you can
tell that I care do you know I mean
people and even though I like to play
like I don't give a [ __ ] like people
always reference to crying episode which
oh oh yeah yeah yeah but like but like
Whitney asked me the other day on her
podcast I did her cons before I did your
podcast but she said she said what do
you ever get insecure and I was like
what and she was like I don't know you
feel like it feels like you always like
[ __ ] roll off your back I'm like man
that's [ __ ] crazy that somebody even
thinks that cuz I got of course you know
I mean that's a comic I mean you're
always yeah
you just i think comedians like I don't
know like they just seem like oh wow
that guy I have a like coming up like
even as a kid like all our comedians
don't give a [ __ ] do it
you're literally up there but they do in
a way they could give a [ __ ] the most so
mouth about every yeah yeah it's it's a
weird [ __ ] like back and forth you
know no no I know what you're saying man
it's like it like if I don't do well on
stage for me if I feel like I didn't do
well even it's a crowd laughs I'm like
I'm bummed the rest of the night yeah
you know you have like a point of
emphasis sometimes I like to go on stage
being like I want to work on this one
thing and no matter what happens around
that one thing as long as that one yeah
I could kill ya but I don't this one
thing right yeah I'll be insecure about
I guess I do like um I guess I do I've
been where I've been doing this tour I
just shot my last special so I think
comes out next year and you have a name
yet not yet okay circling around a few
things but I have uh I have uh I've been
working that tour for a while so now I'm
really got to start to like kind of come
up with your [ __ ] I'm happy I'm happy I
get I get to do that because I the last
tour I did the man on fire one yeah I
was like so sick of that material by the
time I shot it but this one I did for
the same amount of time but I'm like so
excited I was so I didn't get tired of
it do you ever have that like yeah and I
do when I'm weird it makes no sense when
I was doing when I was working on my
thing for my special tool but this is
why I told myself because I was going
out doing club dates to prepare and I
thought I told myself oh I'm only gonna
do my ass one of the shows mmm and the
rest of them I'm gonna do other things
because you do get you start to
second-guess the material you start to
be like you know so I said let me just I
know it and you just want to be
comfortable when you do him another
thing I want to say to you to know just
to give me more compliments is that I've
you know i started i always start
watching your specials and i guys there
was one of your dad directed yeah and i
started watching i was like oh we're at
the Oh r-right now mmm cool you know
that's all just like 10 o'clock at the
or and I was like oh good for you that's
cool
do you get that yeah you've translated
that yeah yeah yeah you know so maybe
that's what you got comfortable doing
and maybe things I don't know my dad
direct the my specials and now my
brother directed my next one it's great
it's really cool yeah oh you guys you
guys are adorable anytime you get it
together I know you your brother your
dad I love that one video about your dad
kissing you yeah yeah yeah you know so
annoying I always kiss my I he did the
other [ __ ] day when I told what I
told my dad I was like hey Dad I'm a
demonic special I was like you're fired
and then he was like what and I was like
turning brother and I said and he's
hired and he was like oh that's awesome
like you know it's like did your brother
wanna do any artsy [ __ ] no no he was
he said to me he's like dude it's it's
interesting directing these specials
because this is it's interesting
directing this special because like you
want it to be good but you don't want
people to notice it that it's good I
mean I know what you mean because then
it's like it's like when you're watching
a movie and it's all edited all [ __ ]
slick you're like all right just chill
let me watch the movie you know oh I
know what you're saying but it's even
worse on a special because you don't you
literally just had to be laughing and if
something hurts you you're like wait
what and it takes you out of that
laughing moment but he got some you know
he did something he did he got a few
different shots than we'd be normally
yet and I really like like he got one
below that's looking up at me and it's
it's it's just really cool and then he
the way he lit it was very cool too so
yeah cuz I've been looking I don't know
if you watch people's specials do you me
I I try to like watch at least a few
minutes and yeah you know they just some
of them are just so this is just some
weird [ __ ] going on out there right now
that I just don't understand really yeah
dude it's like I'm like I love all these
people yeah I'm not trying to talk [ __ ]
I know but I'm just saying as an example
you never mean it's like first of all my
buddy drew our car mark and you know
drunk garage is a weirdo he wants things
to be yes why so talented yeah he's
trying to get different things and so
like you know he do it he produced it I
think he directed drew Michaels all that
though the one know cool crowd yeah so
it was like one of those things he's
like just try that he just did a little
rel special oh yeah that was in the did
you see it I didn't see it yeah that's
thought it was it was like it was so
weird it was just weird you know because
like there's a fan in the shot like
that's just like I'm laughing I'm
talking about our life and like in the
gym of this high school and I had
brought like what the [ __ ] is that fan
in the shower it was almost as if the
high school said you guys can't move
anything I think people like that
special I know that's wrong but it's
like it's one of the ones where you go
oh this is like some different stuff
going on right yeah I know what I mean I
mean I don't know I think we kind of
figured out how to do it
hey be careful with that cord oh yeah
because that's the court of the whole
thing I think it's uh so I'm trying to
do I think the the special I think I
think we figured out how to do it you
know and anything too different is just
like oh we already figured out how to
make specials don't I know but then then
there's like but there's like a there's
a thought process of people being like
well like we've done there's so many
specials because they're not special
brain oh no so they're just they're
content though but it's like isn't the
point of the content is to display this
person skills yeah when all that other
[ __ ] is going on you start to go then it
becomes about that and not to comedy yes
yeah I might my manager always says it I
think the best he's like your special
should be like just a celebration of
what you've been going on tour with it's
just like you know I think that's the
old-school mentality yeah yeah but but
it's also though that the truth is dude
they're not special anymore like I mean
they were especially when it will be an
event when it comes out and now you know
even if you're one of the big guys like
like big like it's like people okay it
comes out and then all right when's the
next one you know another one's gonna be
in another week you know it's gonna be
like Cain like Chappelle did five
specials in two years yeah yeah that's
amazing and you know and people love him
and he's great and and and it's like but
but but not even just that besides his
five that have come out in the last two
years it's every week there's gonna be
if there's you know there's me there's
Jeselnik there's a--there's whatever the
[ __ ] it is Ali Wong it's like they're
all it's just so much content yeah like
I didn't even watch this Chappelle once
oh really because it just I'd be like
yeah I gotta watch it and and then it's
just I don't really watch many specials
but like yeah yeah yeah you know but
he's the kind of person though because
we're in the business and he puts out a
special we literally have to look at it
I looked at a man I I saw the one clip
about the Jesse Smollett that that bit
is so [ __ ] funny to me when he keeps
calling um juicy smell yeah yeah
dude that [ __ ] killed me he's so good
you know what the thing I loved about
his last question was like how
comfortable he was yeah that's the thing
I took from it the most it wasn't even
about the material it wasn't even like
you know because at disdain days I could
say it's just content so here's somebody
here's one of our Giants in the game
talking about stuff yeah so he go okay I
know he's gonna hit these topics yeah
yeah yeah I mean but but just the way I
was like this is how we all have to get
to yeah it's at this point yeah cuz you
seem very comfortable when you're doing
your so yes yeah but but is that because
like what is that from you so okay
honestly what I think it's from for real
I've thought about this a lot because
people III think that um because I I
have had so much love in my life like my
parents and my family and [ __ ] and like
that I just feel like I
everything's gonna be okay no matter
what um and that's the [ __ ] deep deep
[ __ ] thought but like I feel like you
know what this could all crash and burn
right now I [ __ ] made it
yeah you think it's your brother you got
I got it all I'm happy uh you know and
and and I don't as much as I need to be
on stage to make people laugh and to
make me [ __ ] laugh
I don't you know I already have the bare
necessity of I have love now and I think
that because my parents were so good
when I was coming up when I was growing
up rather um they always made me feel
like I mattered and like it's you know I
feel like I I you know it's very
fortunate dude like that's why your dad
is great
your dad's great that's why every
holiday i text you say yo what's up
because like I've been on a set with him
and it's like that's how he makes the
set see ya he's a [ __ ] great guy you
know he's like so that's why and then
but that's interesting that you say that
be yeah I think that's what it is I've
thought about it a lot cuz people
comment on it you know they'll be like
because they know that I've had like
because people there's the thing I talk
about at my new in my new special coming
out but like people think that comedians
they romanticize this thing as like oh
you have you had a fucked-up childhood
right and like I didn't and so I would
think like well what is that cubby
because people say
coming coming from pain but like it you
know does it I don't know yes sure it
can but like you know uh yeah I don't
know I just I think we just make I think
they will say that it's because we make
the pain funny
ya know that that is right yeah that's
all this so that's something that you
focus on cuz like for me like my mom has
dementia right you know I'm dealing with
that right now right in a way I'm
dealing with it as I talk about it all
sure and even if you're not talking
about it on stage you're still escaping
it yeah that's what actually I'm
escaping at first I just happen to be
talking about Russ stagers right right
right
gotcha I just had a situation like this
past weekend I was in Oxnard and my
parents I have them in this retirement
place out in Oxnard you know and so uh
okay yes and you were doing I was doing
you know so alright my stepdad just
brought her to the show oh and even know
I don't even know thank God I wasn't
doing this material oh yeah you know I
tell how if I do what what is doing
she's guys you know she would be like
what do you forget it yeah it's a weird
in such a weird as [ __ ] but I'm over it
I was over right away but I didn't
initially I was like the shock but I
thought about like how much how much I
just reveal of myself on stage and like
you you don't necessarily do that yeah I
used to not do that the last man on fire
I definitely didn't do that and then
this new one I talked about more about
my childhood oh you're not personal yeah
but it made of fire I was I just I the
thing is is I I like doing that and I
know people like to hear about you yeah
but um I still want to be just silly
about everyday you know like yeah you
know like like like like the best at
that Regan like Brian Regan like he's
talking about refrigerators yes you
could do for an hour just know my new
great about the morning show of why I no
no but I know what you said but yeah I
get it but you're like silly like you
like being silly
i I did I really like being so yeah but
not to not to cut you off but I did like
the first two specials i I had it all
kind of planned out like the first two
specials I thought my first special I
just want to talk about [ __ ]
makes me laugh that's always made me
laugh for the past however many years
I've been alive the second special there
was in court that was white male black
comic that would you came up with the
title that's right the the incorrigible
the second one was there was more of
that it was more of that I always felt
like it was a little bit more point of
view but I always felt like it was the
b-side of what why my black comic would
be okay and after that I was like all
right that was all the [ __ ] I thought
was funny and silly and wacky and so for
man how far I was like let's let's I'm
30 whatever it was 35 let's talk a
little bit more about my actual point of
view and who I [ __ ] You Know Who I am
a little bit I've always had this notion
about how everyone thought they were the
lead of their own movie and that's kind
of what I made this special about yeah
that was a great bit thanks dude
and so I called it manna fire because I
talked about man on fire Denzel
Washington around I think so he's them
and then so this one is more like that
as well but I cuz I always wanted to do
that like [ __ ] silly [ __ ] and get it
kinda out of the way I was looking I'll
get that other way cuz I'm not gonna be
I knew I was gonna be able to do that
forever yeah you gotta grow up you can
write you know I mean you gotta have
kids your fans grow with you if you're
fun [ __ ] 50 years old talking about
the new app or candy crush it's like you
know what I mean Who am I I gotta
giggles my candy crush baby thanks Chris
yeah no no bro you know what I know what
you're saying though cuz I felt the same
way even like I feel like if I'm
starting to work on ya material right
now I'm going like so I'm talking about
this personal stuff about my mom but I'm
also thinking like well maybe I have to
like dude should I should I start
wearing a suit should I start wearing
you know you know to me looks like
should I start you know at a certain way
I mean yeah how long you gonna be able
to wear sneakers and you know I don't
know I don't know if that I don't know
if that has anything to do with it or
not maybe it does but like I you know
the other thing too I was talking to
actually my tattoo artist dr. Wu about
this who [ __ ] just in my new one he's
this [ __ ]
shoutout to him he was like he's like
maybe two or three years younger than me
but he was you know I'm 39 he's 36 maybe
and he was like um we were talking we
got into talking about how people make
fun of how like I dress like a young and
I'm like I don't really thought about
that like yeah cuz I'm so young about
yeah yeah [ __ ] talk about dicks on
stage yeah dude you're 50 I got it
almost all right but I'm saying I know I
wouldn't even think that I'm you know
and but you know what it is though it's
it's it's the thing is it's because
we're so visible now with things like
this yeah so there's so therefore we
don't I don't know if we really
understand how we look to other people
yeah
so then the regular folks are like
looking at you and like to you know they
like the guys want to be you and right I
mean so they're like but then they're
gonna get to a point where they're gonna
be like oh that guy's he's 40
yeah I don't think I'm at the point yet
where I look but I don't think I'll know
until right late so so but but my but
dr. Wu was saying he was like dude when
are you supposed to dress all like
flashy and nice she's like a nobody
who's 22 as money yeah I was like man
that's true I know you know so it's like
now I have money I can wear this stuff I
get a roll and yeah but I mean but it's
like you know it's like but this is not
what they say with the parent first of
all I'm not surprised that when you were
35 is when you said now it's time for me
to be adult yeah that's just a man's
journey right you know I mean like 35
when we start to go oh how do I get my
[ __ ] together yeah and I was and I was
it took me a while to [ __ ] grow up
like bro I was I was in no but I mean
just in not even thinking about anybody
else until like a few years ago like not
even thinking about anyone else never
thought about my future right was just
like some kook yeah a big [ __ ] idiot
and then always huh you know what's
funny this is it's I've been like that
too man
because I started late so I got into
entertainment late so I was like I'm
living the life of like somebody who's
supposed to be 10 years younger than ya
as I was trying to do it so but then
like then when this thing happened to my
mom I started to think [ __ ] yeah I
gonna do yeah so that's when I started
like I started I've been working out
watching what I eat I'm trying to get my
health together I used to be in good
shape looking at it yeah you got to do
that it's just there's so much [ __ ] out
there that's so easy to eat [ __ ] it's
hard I mean it's hard
people people for some reason because I
I work out and I post it because I the
reason why I post my work out sometimes
on Instagram story is because
I now if I don't post one every like
week or so they think you're getting
there like that yeah
and so it's motivation for me to
actually go to the gym which is insane
but it's boss what happened you're gonna
get that bro you know so um so yeah so I
I just uh I don't know man
I mean I already feel like I'm like I
always have a lower back thing my
[ __ ] ch4 arm hurts now you know it's
like dude welcome to four time today
yeah that's my take money is for no
[ __ ] reason I just I'm just like out
what happened here you know as I'm
trying or I'm trying to cut my toenail
and my knee pops it's it's the worst
dude all right here's some more
questions for you so when did you like
when I went to go
I was in San Diego and I went to go you
know see you in San Diego and I just
thought damn and I look at your posts
that's the real thing I'm really trying
to say is like it's like how was it for
you to go from like you're doing clubs
and now you're just like a huge theatre
act and I feel like it's only gonna get
bigger but like how do you feel out of
touch at all sometimes to let go but
that's what's great about the comedy
strong yes duty zombies for keeps just a
hundred percent dude I tell also like
new guys coming up like I was just
telling this to another buddy but I was
like dude you have to always come back
to eat the Comedy Store and you gotta do
[ __ ] shows if you're coming up you got
to keep you how to keep doing open mic
you can't just you know some of these
guys younger guys now they have fan
bases and they don't even do stand-up I
know have from online dude just because
you could sell it ticket to your fans
doesn't mean you're funny
so you just say that again so you gotta
get the people that aren't your fans you
got to get on stage at the Comedy Store
that's why I all come up with a bit in
[ __ ] Orlando at my show just [ __ ]
doing it of course they'll laugh cuz
they know me they [ __ ] they've been
waiting for me to come there you got to
test it I'll go I'll go on after Rogan
yeah I'll go on after Sebastian I'll go
on after [ __ ] you after whoever other
people they're not all there for me and
I'll be able to tell if I can't get that
full room to lie I love that's what I
love about the Comedy Store yeah exactly
what you're saying just is in that
trance
turn some energy to depending on who it
is yes you know especially somebody like
that I even and sometimes it's like I'm
if everybody's in town that I get
pushback but it's like even it's still a
great spot oh yeah but then I know I'm
like oh well this crowd is beat of that
that's a good not that you need to still
do that but that's a good workout focus
yeah so then so you do keep yourself
grounded that way but like but oh how
was it going from like you know it but
also before I even get to that let me
just say this like hearing you say even
ask me that question feels weird to me
that you think that I'm that successful
so like I still feel like there's [ __ ] I
got to do yeah I don't even feel like
like when you say like uh you know your
rise like it's so weird to me that even
I even have I had a rise but this is
what I'm saying about the comedy this is
what I'm saying about it's all about
perspective and this is why it's hard to
hang out with people who I don't want to
use the words like on your level that's
not that's not the word I want to use
but it is hard to be around people who
aren't on the same journey because
they're gonna look and be like they're
gonna hear you say something like you
you think you have more to do and
there's some guy who's gonna be like
what are you talking about man I wish I
had a podcast you know but it's like but
this is what it takes to really make it
this is why I said in in that I said
it's only gonna get bigger yeah you know
what I mean but it's like no do you
listen you you don't know but you've had
it you've had a great run yeah like you
don't you and I and I what I like about
is I've seen it from the minute I've
seen from the beginning yeah you mean
from going the different the different
roads did you take it so like so here
you are you did Carnegie Hall yeah yeah
it's a trip man if I really [ __ ] I don't
stop and think about it though you gotta
stop not of course I gonna be like damn
I did when I was there yeah when I was
at Carnegie Hall Wow
yeah man it's just um dude everybody's
on their own path and it's really [ __ ]
fortunate I you know I work really hard
and and also I'm [ __ ] lucky man you
gotta have luck you gotta have [ __ ]
things go your way and I'm really
fortunate to have that happen you know
I've worked very hard but also you have
to have some luck I mean dude
when you get to a certain level nobody
funnier than another person it's just
like dude like some people are gonna
like Tom Segura more than they're gonna
like me and some people gonna like Ali
Wong more than they like me and that's
fine I don't want to be the guy who goes
up and and and I when I'm at the Comedy
Store
did some nights it's like are you
[ __ ] [ __ ] me all these guys are
here I know it's like [ __ ] Logan Burr
and and I'm in the middle of it I'm like
I'm like I don't even [ __ ] belong
here but but but I do because I've
worked hard and and I don't I don't want
everybody not everybody's gonna like me
the best and that's fine they're gonna
like some people gonna walk out be like
Adalia was okay but Sebastian was my was
the my favorite yeah that's good that's
how it's gonna be that's how I want it
that's how it should be that's why it's
[ __ ] awesome dude you go there and
you get you get the guys that appeal to
different people you know well I think
your appreciation for it is something
that I've always admired - you know
there's a moment I don't know we've
never talked about this but this is a
moment what like if I had like you know
you have those signature moments in a
person's friendship you know I mean
remember something about someone I'm
like you shared but I'll never forget
this dude it was the first time your
name was on the marquee at the Comedy
Store
I'll never forget it because you we were
taught you were like go you said to me
do you got to see this yeah yeah yeah
you know and you took me outside and you
were like looking up at it and I looked
at your face and I was like wow oh
really this really means a lot to you Oh
like you just were so and I was like
that's alright it was one of those
moments I thought to myself oh you're
gonna really this is you gonna take off
huh you know I mean but I remember that
and there's there's people that don't
even feel that way about that yeah
but so that's why I'm saying I feel like
you have hmm look when I look back on my
career I always think of it like I'm on
a treadmill and it's set to one mm-hmm
okay so I have to wait a long time
before I look back and go oh [ __ ] I
actually have done some things yours is
probably at like a six you know what I
mean
yeah hey you get higher than that is
trouble by the way people help you like
I gotta like this guy no no no no no
little bad I know what you said it's
like yeah but that's the world we live
in right now and by the way like being
funny is not even the prerequisite for
like why people come and watch people no
no no no you know it's it's yeah I
that's what people have to get stop
thinking about all the time it's like
there's something about being likable
there's something about being like
whatever whatever that thing is that
sparks people to go I want to go watch
that guy everybody has that there's a
ton of guys we can mention that we
probably won't but yeah are [ __ ] yeah
like I don't get it
yeah but but he's a nice guy I like the
guy he's my friend or something
right and [ __ ] good people like him
[ __ ] good yeah that helps us yeah and
also good for that guy man for figuring
it out it's hard enough yeah it's hard
enough without us like trying to drain
now I would say I have like five like
what I people that I would consider like
oh I'm really close to this person then
I would be like I gotta leave the room
when they go Austin I don't know but you
know what is funny about that about the
comedy store though is like I don't know
how many people are like like how many
people you feel there do you feel like
oh these are my colleagues
or like these are my friends cuz cuz I
always talk about this it's like
sometimes I go it's when life events
happen you know somebody gets married or
I have a baby or something like that if
I don't know about it yeah I'm like oh
I'm not really this person's friend yeah
I don't know I mean all right there's a
few guys that are at the Comedy Store
that are my actual friends yeah and then
there are but like like good friends
like you yeah and then there are like
for sure friends yeah like you know
maybe I've hung out with them solo once
or something but like usually in a group
setting but you know I don't know I feel
most I feel close to most of the guys
there yeah close-ish but you make that
you write and contribute to that yeah I
feel like like like a friend to me as
somebody that you could reach out to on
text about something right run yeah you
know I could do that with a ton of the
guy yeah but deal but see I don't even
know if I would even consider that a
friend
yeah yeah a friend yeah yeah cuz I even
like it
it's funny you like Sebastian got
married right and I didn't even know you
didn't know and I was like I was like I
thought him and I were close funny he's
also really like but still then he told
me he doesn't like you though and we
would travel that's why you guys went to
Bobby like if Bobby were to get marry
and I wasn't there yeah he would be dead
to me yeah yeah you know what I mean
like cuz that's somebody I'm like yeah
yeah you know that you know and yeah
he's doing good now by the way he's a
you know oh yes yeah he called me
yesterday just telling he was like the
therapy and all this so good send out
some love advice for Bobby Lee love
Bobby
maybe he'll start returning text now and
like you know being like a baby ever
yeah okay I can't stand that dude but um
I don't know dude
it's just did this the ride they were on
right now it's like it's I guess I
always had to keep things in perspective
you know cuz I cuz to be at the Comedy
Store is to be around every level of
comedy yeah isn't it crazy that's the
truth yeah it is crazy Brett aren't said
to me once he was like we were on the
patio of the Comedy Store and people
were like coming up to all of the
comedians and you know fans and Shedden
and he was like dude isn't this [ __ ]
insane I was like what and he was like
this is like if you go to like Dodger
Stadium and like you also are hanging
out in the dugout yeah but I'm like man
yeah you're right huh
you know you do kind of but it's just a
lack of respect for comedians though
yeah but also the comedy business you're
hanging out where the fans are yeah like
it's so [ __ ] weird dude yeah it is
when we think about it like sometimes we
just well Rogan goes does his show and
they goes bright in the back room yeah
but sometimes he's in the hallways but
it gets ridiculous for him you won't go
on the patio but do something but here's
the thing though I've been standing in
the hallway and Chris Rock yeah just a
strolling through the hallway right like
that's crazy
yeah cuz all the crazy people that hang
out at the Comedy Store they just
they're yeah I know you know the down
embarrass people they're just walking by
Chris Rock like this yeah yeah you know
me
walking by LeBron James you'd be like oh
[ __ ] LeBron you know people I feel like
it I don't know it's it's such a weird
thing man it's such a weird thing like I
say all different levels you had the
door guys you have open mic people all
the way to like and here's Dave
Chappelle pops in hears like you know
all these types of people you know I
hope you always had that time where we
can like like the days when we went to
101 so much yeah you know what yeah I
mean they everybody's so busy now that I
just don't do that enough anymore and
now but you know yeah I don't know I
guess I guess a lot of us feel like so
like fortunate that we're working that
we just want to keep working I mean like
I mean I don't know man I just I'm happy
people [ __ ] keep coming back like if
you see me like that's the other thing
we're talking about like you can make
money as a comedian and you don't even
need to be funny but like will they come
back we'll attack yeah yeah like a lot
of this [ __ ] like the internet guys
they'll do a money grab tour and it's
just like nobody's gonna come back and
the club's doing a money grab - yeah the
places are doing money grabs there just
like we got this guy he's gonna sell out
whatever whatever yeah but it's crazy I
don't know you know it's funny he's like
I I know you
so I I've watched your eyes and I could
see it I could track it but like
Sebastian yeah dude I it's as if like
one day yeah I look on my Instagram and
like he's out I know yeah he sold out
the Chicago Stadium and I was like what
I have to say I hate when people say
[ __ ] like this but I always thought he
was gonna be that big really yep I never
thought he wasn't gonna be big I'm just
saying yeah you didn't see it I didn't
see like it was it was like he went
underground and the next thing you know
you were like whoa it s showing time
[ __ ] killed it for him and then I've
been show time killed a friend I think
about show time is people are paying
it's not net it's not Netflix if you
have show time you have money yeah yeah
yeah everyone has Netflix if you have
Showtime also you're rich I understand
so that means you can you can buy
tickets yeah so that was what made
Sebastian really popular and then when
his [ __ ] got off Showtime and went onto
Netflix game over
game over game over so yeah that guy did
what Madison Square Garden for time yeah
I was like crazy the first time I
started to notice is when that Forbes
think yeah yeah yeah that was like I
thought he was like number seven happen
so that's great but without the reason
why I'm bringing that up is like I
really enjoyed that this this is the
first time in a while that actually just
being a comic as a viable thing yeah
because when you first got into it
didn't you didn't you think I'm gonna do
comedy and then I'm gonna be a movie
star did you always want to be a KY
always wanted to do stand-up always
wanted to do stand-up I was I was like I
would never if I got there I would never
stop doing stand-up but when I first
heard somebody told me that Damon Wayans
senior nah our friend Damon Wayans made
50 grand at the weekend it had the
[ __ ] Irvine improv or something like
right I was like did I hear you
correctly I know who when I first
realized and I had been doing stand-up I
was like he made what now yeah I did not
know you could make that kind of money
doing stand-up um yeah so but I know
what you mean that's the thing is like
so it was when I was coming up it was
like a means to an end you know yes yeah
yeah get yet to become a movie star you
know that was like this that was the
other thing too is like um Eddie Murphy
Jim Carrey these guys Steve Martin these
guys who did stand-up stopped doing
right so I guess we just thought oh you
just kind of don't make money doing it
you just do that you know that's what I
thought yeah yeah I remember that too I
remember doing a oh man day it's funny
you say about Damon Wayans I I remember
I covered I was like the host or
something from one of his shows at
Irvine yeah time yeah and he had you
know he came in like a sweat suit yeah
yeah yeah he had his phone he was
looking through the phone yeah yeah some
bits yeah and then I heard that T was
like oh yeah is like a 50 55 60 mm all
weekend and that's the first time I
thought of myself but see he was so
famous I thought well you have to be
that big that's what I thought
that's what I thought you don't have to
be that big you don't have
Bagon you just have to be you know
popular and people have to come see you
yeah so it's like but now it's like a
it's like the end it could be the end
now so it's like this is a path that
could be uh you know and you that's all
you ever have to do but you used to
think like like George Wallace is like
that I mean that guy's got to be rolling
it but George Wallace I never thought he
wanted to be an actor or anything like
that yeah just a comical audio I just
want to be a comic bro but now look at
like now you could just get a stir I did
a 100 million dollar zombie movie for
three months and that and I'm not
telling you what I got paid here because
that would be obviously you know stupid
like just like no reason to but like the
pay cut that you've gotta take to do a
movie for three months is just
unbelievable do you hear about this
Kalin was telling me the same thing
Kalin was tall yeah Khaled yeah Kalin
was like you know it's almost a pay cut
to do a television show well let's get
real Callens probably [ __ ] lucky he's
completed shell-bed yeah he talked [ __ ]
about you and he was on here - sure I
was just with him last night dude he's
[ __ ] stuff yeah he's he's one of
those smart funny guys
yeah he he he ya know he he does he does
does he do theater so I don't even know
even I don't know he's gonna be like
Sebastian such he's almost like an alt
comic good like we're like what you're
doing is not what people do on stage
yeah he's the only person I'm okay with
being on offstage yeah if I had to pick
one person only one okay cuz there's a
certain thing about her way he put his
persona that cuz yeah other people I'll
be like oh no turn it keep that [ __ ] on
stage but he's one of those he's one of
those ones man yeah I'm surprised you
guys haven't done some kind of like
we're working on it it's it's uh it's
you know we gotta do the right thing but
yeah we wonder what the right thing
right thing but it's got to feel right
it's got to be like you know the right
show the right whatever you know
what mean well what what do you mean
first of all what should we do
oh no that's what I'm saying we gotta
wait for the right thing I don't know I
can see you guys Munich on a cop's show
on Fox yeah but then what is it was it
your dream don't you want to be like you
don't you want to have a gun oh that's
movie yeah but isn't that what you
always wanted don't you want to be like
double-oh-seven 100% I'm generals to do
this action movie coming up in January
we'll see oh [ __ ] are you gonna be like
the star no nope nope no I don't want to
be the star yet oh we're yet at 39
because I don't want I don't want no but
what I mean is I want to do a few where
I'm not to stop oh my god you've tested
out see how people feel about it yeah
it's like boom boom and then like a
couple buddy comedy yeah yeah and then
you have your Beverly Hills Cop yes that
used to be like what I thought you had
to do that's right that's how [ __ ]
like David Schwimmer well I think he's
great but like he was on for a lot of
these friends guys did it they they were
[ __ ] big on friends and then all of a
sudden they're the lead in a movie you
can't do that you know your movie career
goes yeah I think maybe you can do it
now but like back then people are like
whoa whoa whoa hold on
we got a disguise it didn't work for any
of them they all fine except for you
know Jennifer Aniston I'll be like The
Big Bang Theory guys like yeah it's like
you gotta be the [ __ ] third or fourth
banana you know yeah I mean I don't know
he's as funny you said to me the other
night like Seinfeld was at the Comedy
Store you know you were like you know oh
yeah the [ __ ] guy has no idea we're
hilarious again at the Comedy Store
that's why we still go there cuz how hum
yeah yeah yeah yeah I mean it's [ __ ]
Seinfeld I don't give a [ __ ] I mean it's
no but I'm just saying it's still like
you know yeah because you have a way you
know we walk around like peacocks yeah
you know and then there's like a billion
it's so funny it's like and you are yeah
I don't even want to talk to him I just
walk by him and shook hands with
Sebastian and went into the main room
you know I always feel like I'm gonna
bother that guy you don't seem like that
guy anyway yeah but you like budget but
then you had your big mm go yeah yeah
yeah yeah that those are the kinds of
things that like where it's like [ __ ]
dude it's like those are the things that
you don't
expect to happen like as a comedian the
goal is to get the SPECIAL the goal is
to do whatever five minutes on [ __ ]
corner whatever your goal is all right
those are all the goals get a comedy
album whatever [ __ ] dude
if you had told me yeah this is gonna
lead to you playing Eminem in a video
and then him playing you in a video yeah
you'd be like get the [ __ ] out of here
but the weird part about it is it's like
cuz you have a lot of celebrity fans
yeah I mean that's the thing people love
comedy yeah yeah yeah no no they do they
don't even think about that but yeah
think about that people it's just in the
same way that like like you know
athletes listen to rap so there you know
people a lot of people love comedy so
it's like here's a guy who's now a fan
of yours yeah it's like you know that's
the thing like and you're in a position
now where these are the kind of people
that you know they'll have like they're
people like hey reach out to that yeah
yeah yeah yeah do some such girls like
that so I know but that was like it but
you know what the funny thing too is
like you were to me you were already big
yeah you were already big so it's like
people can't be like Oh Eminem oh yes
yes I know you already yeah yeah that's
why they found you people always say
different [ __ ] anyway it's like so funny
is like dude like all haters would be
like whatever you wouldn't even be
anything if you weren't didn't do the
Bieber roast I'm like what it's so funny
when people say [ __ ] like that because
it's like dude that's just what you know
me from you're just like you say I don't
even know who you people a lot of haters
will say [ __ ] like why do we know who
you were if it wasn't for Bieber to put
you on it's like dude you're just you
just don't know really what's going on
yeah yeah you know me from that yeah you
know me from that doesn't mean I forget
other people know me from that by the
way I was always pissed off about that
what you're not even a Bieber fan okay
what hate I listen to the acoustic album
but then he came to the he came to ya
know he I think he was really he's a fan
of comedy yeah yeah yeah no he wanted me
to be on that I was over feeling like I
was walking I was in the Laugh Factory
one time I went upstairs and then he's
sitting there with like whatever
whatever you know and I I I see him and
he says to his girl he's like yo look
have to do for more kohai yeah yeah you
know I'm thinking myself oh that's right
yeah yeah we don't even know you know we
don't say but it's like you talk about
famous that dude took a picture of me in
him and put it on his thing uh-huh I you
know I have my notifications on yeah
four months straight it was like you
know you know yeah your thing must be
like you know what I'm I know okay okay
but you do engage with you do engage
with fans sometimes yeah well I'll yeah
I tried to stop I don't do it as much
because it's just [ __ ] usually leads
to like negative [ __ ] like engage with
your haters that's all I'm saying that's
what I'm saying okay I try to stop doing
that because it's just [ __ ] it's like
why it was fun for a while yeah because
it's funny to me yeah yeah yeah I know I
know yeah I think people I didn't
realize that people also like I don't
know like some people now I'm like I'll
have a lot I'll have like not just my
fans see my stuff like I'll tweet some
and then other people will see it cuz it
gets retweeted yeah yeah yeah a lot
people don't know who I am to be like
who's this guy so those people will see
that and that'll be there intro to me oh
and I'll just see me angry
yes I'm not right good so I just kind of
like I got to think about that so I
think about that now I hate see I don't
like I want to engage with the hater
sometimes because sometimes somebody
will say something you just want to be
like you piece of [ __ ] like yeah like
what are you talking about and then you
like but I hate giving them anything
yeah it's like hard yeah but they don't
hate giving it to them because I think
it's like I imagine them like and
[ __ ] they'll never see this and then
oh [ __ ]
like that to me it's like bro you
entered the Octagon what did you think
was gonna happen I know dude I know but
it's like it's like but it's a no-win
situation i i i retweeted a girl the
other day that said something about me
negative i don't remember what it was
but i just retweeted it I don't mean the
guy said anything about it and everyone
just was like you [ __ ] suck you [ __ ]
it to her like and I just delete my time
retweet and in my head I'm like well she
can delete the tweet yeah if she doesn't
want any more of this but then it was
just so brutal that I was like
I want to [ __ ] oh I just took Isis
took it off retweet and then somebody
was like why'd you on retweet it and I
was like because you guys are being
[ __ ] [ __ ] I got retweeted yeah
yeah no I know what you mean doing this
I know I don't wanna [ __ ] make
somebody kill themselves you don't want
to at least like it or like beep I don't
want to put ruin someone's [ __ ] day
well but even though they even though
they you're going out of their way to
yeah but but it's like let them that's I
know I don't know I it's it's like the
the Internet is still such a negative
place I asked Rogan about it I was like
when did you stop did you when did you
stop looking at comments like say on you
- yeah like when did you stop you know
nothing for me I cuz I cuz sometimes you
look and he's saying even the good
comments or comments that you have to
like not look at yeah I know he said
that he doesn't look at the [ __ ] I got a
guy I actually don't I am way better
than I was I really am like I don't know
also Kurds are too many now I can't look
it up right but and I never look at
YouTube comments but like you know
tweets I don't look at Twitter a lot of
the replies I look at the top ones on
Instagram to see if like [ __ ] you
know somebody said Machine Gun Kelly
says guys I follow me that I'm like oh I
like doing that or I like going to like
the verified section yeah and then
looking to see who's following you cuz
they're not go like oh what that person
follows me yeah you'd be surprised who's
a fan and who's a fan of you man so yeah
I have some good I have like six really
good followers but they don't ever
engage yeah it's not like I ever get it
like you know I mean just even beepers
the only person that like like is after
the roast and I said some hey good job
bubble boom and then one day my [ __ ]
[ __ ] was on fire again I was like what's
happening right now and it was cuz he
like he retweeted something like that so
but you're you're let your that's you
now you're doing chef Rubino man all
right [ __ ]
what time is it all right I did it you
did it I know I had him on you know
we'll never see him again I Love You Man
I'll come again yeah well one of my
special comes out or something yeah yeah
idea but guys this is my good buddy
mr. Chris D'Elia yeah he's got a new
special coming out unnamed he's still
working on that yeah but you can find
all this information you know what you
know the guy if you're in the podcast
but if you're watching my podcast you
know exactly who this is
but I'll still have his information
below check out his congratulations
podcast come to the college storm
watches both rolled off the I know what
I'm on I'm on you coming up this show oh
yeah oh sweet
the junior season rather here and I
enjoyed you on the good doctor oh yeah I
still get hate from that because I
played like a dad what a [ __ ] dick
that show dude every other episode I'm
terren oh yeah I know I should that show
it's so like they were it's really a
heart-wrenching so yeah so he was the
devil on that show so you can all you
can watch that [ __ ] on Hulu I watch it
on Hulu but anyways yeah so make sure
you would check out this funny man and
see him already a giant in the comedy
business he doesn't think so but I think
so
a giant in the comedy business and it
can only get better I'm waiting for you
to I'm waitin to see your post about
like cuz you could usually from New York
New Jersey yeah you jerk your friend so
like do you see yourself being in like
New Jersey doing like a like a stadium
yeah maybe the thing is I'm from [ __ ]
la olla - it says 12 so yeah yeah I
don't know I think I'm gonna play Radio
City next yeah so we'll see no I know
what you good cuz you're gonna go on
another tour eventually yeah I don't
know when that'll start but alright well
Chris is gonna go on another tour and
you know maybe I'll come I'll come to
some spots yeah you know I mean I did it
with Dane yeah but he took me on a
private jet so I want to go me doing
that I'll take the private jet and all
thank you
I'm like wow a mile southwest
I can even get an upgrade but any we'll
see what happens but anyways thanks for
coming on the show and this is being
Christie Leah thanks for watching
different with Griffin card share and
all that stuff and I see you next week